okay i have siri by my side give me a
random number
between one and eight
okay siri is mute right now
oh siri just started playing music okay
give me a random number between one and
eight
it's seven seven okay all brown good
luck
um
i'm going to play a a different opening
than usual
actually no i'm going to play a similar
opening to what i usually have been
playing
uh this petrov line
i'm going to try and win as quickly as
possible
even if it involves playing dubious
moves
ah did someone challenge me and then
just log off and that's what happened
okay uh the first dubious move knight c6
i only learned this recently this is
called the staffer gambit and
it's not a good opening for black if
white is a strong player
but i think it's a very effective
opening if
light is like below 16 1700
i think there's just so many traps
there's
many positions where okay blacks acts
upon very early
but gets a lot of a lot of tactical
tricks
so i take with the d-pawn i want to
accelerate my development
and okay we'll see what happens here i'm
gonna play bishop to c5
i don't think i want to say too much
that bishop c5 is useful move
attacking f2 maybe ideas of this
what time control do i prefer anything
between like one minute
to 10 minutes
i would say
i mean if you want to challenge me to
longer games that's okay too
because syria is just determining my
fate
uh okay
d3 was d3
i think d3 is uh it's a natural move but
it allows this move
and that would be
that would be problematic for white g4
okay i haven't studied the stafford
gambit opening too extensively
um so i haven't familiarized myself with
all of the traps but i think this is one
of the traps
where white just can't defend f2 unless
he wants to play this
but then i'll get initiative
hmm
who can i mod i want to mod someone
because there's no mods in the chat
i don't want to be doing mod work while
playing
um now okay now the question is do i
take with the bishop
or the knight because both seem
attractive
i could take tick tick we need to
feel like position i should just take
with the bishop
or with the knight and then keep my
bishop
yeah i think that's a it's a decision
you can kind of use judgment
you don't have to rely on calculation
because now these dark squares are just
so weak
similar to the last game where i i was
the only player with the dark sword
bishop
it's a very powerful situation you can
essentially control half the board
white has a hard time fighting for these
squares
wait coldplayer9 1992 sounds really
familiar i think he's another streamer
are you the person who i rated the other
day and the other day
like before that too
i was inspired by your layout i think
like one of the best chess layouts that
i've seen
okay queen f3 i think i'll play bishop
d4 unless there's a battery move
play bishop h6 question is do i want to
prevent him from casting queen cider
kingside
i think i want him to castle queenside
i'll play bishop d4
okay congratulations coldplayer uh
you have been awarded the mod title
old player 1992.
just because there's no mods here i
usually like to have at least one mod
in addition i usually have like to have
at least one dark sword bishop
such a good bishop
and if he castles queenside then i'm i'm
gonna try and go all out
to attack bishop here queen here queen
here
it's a difficult position for white
because okay this bishop's kind of stuck
he could develop it but then he can't
castle kingside
the slide is kind of tied down to
defending the pawn
i guess i have to figure out what to do
as well this will start with bishop here
just improve
put the ball in white's court this feels
like tennis
just want the ball to stay in his court
gain some time
queen f4 so he wants to maybe improve
the bishop further
well this would be in my favor because
of tactics
let's play queen e7 it's a flexible move
keeping him guessing which way i want to
castle
maybe also ideas of this move
prototyper thanks for the follow
so he plays knight d1 which is actually
probably a decent move
defending the b-pawn and wanting to play
c3
isn't there a saying always play f6
it's okay in this position i want to
play bishop e5 with tempo
i guess one key line is that if he plays
c3
bishop ooh he checks me but i can play
g6
i don't think that helped him
now i'm going to castle queen side
bishop e5 will still someday come with
tempo
um and what i wanted to say that
like when he moves the queen and
threatening d4 i can play c5 restricting
d4
he moves his bishop again i can play f5
and the center is about to open up
always have to be cautious when your
queen or when your king is on the same
file as your opponent's queen
uh because now now i have a few options
play bishop d5 check play bishop take a2
check bishop take f5 check
since all these moves he's probably
going to play king d2
what's the most effective maybe just
bishop take f5 rook f8
keep some initiative
his pieces are a hundred percent beef
they need to stay fresh i do not get
that analogy
um but my pieces feel fresh i guess
so rook f8
or goth or queen b4
wait a minute he's going to play king c1
and run away
i'm looking for like tactical ways to
stop him
like bishop f6 you can take on f5 with
check
okay i'm going to start with this
i have one rook on the same file as this
queen and one rook on the same file as
this king
also i have a donation so weed or bonsky
or is it david sometimes i struggle with
w's
thank you that weed for the the five
wait what did he do he did something he
donated five dollars
thanks so much really appreciate that
and thank you idawid for the follow
okay so i'm keeping the initiative
attacking his queen and his king still
on d2
those queen is probably going to move
somewhere g4
ideally i want to get queen g5 in that
might be
difficult
also try and get bishop f4 in
okay this looks nice hello lord
pineapple
good to see you back hello caveman
hello to everyone else who i didn't say
hi to already
oniti really likes this color for
leeches okay
this dark color
i like it too uh this should be made
very soon
i think this is force mate somehow i
guess he could play knight e3
oh maybe it's not it's not even force me
thanks lord pineapple for for following
and thanks karma for 100 bits
okay time to not get distracted the
knight is pinned
this is definitely not force mate
my rook is pinned oh i want to play like
queen b4
ah i have an idea i'm going to play rook
e8
idea only works as if he plays uh
rook he one rook ae one's better i
wanted to play this and win the rook
maybe i just play king b8
unpin myself and then threaten rook
to e5 shiva love thanks for the follow
and hello to 99 mira from argentina nice
i want to go to argentina someday i
haven't been to too
too many like south american countries
am i just winning this so now i'm up a
piece i still have my dark squared
bishop
what to do okay this is my
this is my gun my alekhine's gun
someday i'll i'll use it to be
aggressive
but in reality i might just want to play
queen b4 in this and meet him
hello to zen toss a lot of new names
today
good to see some new people i'm gonna
play a5
create luft go for the pawn storm
what is asado oh is that barbecue
or is that grilled or something
poyo asado is grilled chicken if i'm not
mistaken
uh queen g4 is controlling this
okay let's just try and convert this uh
let's play queen
d6 target the pawn
try and play a bit quicker too
hello to jeep to see your jeep
today where am i i'm in uh st louis
i was in london yesterday i was in
prague like three days ago
i was in spain a couple weeks ago
i continually have to adjust to new time
zones
is it super dollar dollar sign to travel
the world and play chess
um it's not as expensive as you would
think
uh i'm very into like travel hacking
and finding ways to like optimize
travels
and still travel like with comfort
i don't know if too many people know
this but like when you reach
the im level like if you get if you have
like the im or gm title you can play in
a lot of international events
where tournament organizers will provide
uh like hotel or food so the two
european tournaments i played in
um were generous enough to provide uh
like lodging and breakfast which
makes it a lot more affordable
i'm also very passionate about finding
cheap flights
um like one of the reasons i go through
london is because it's just so much
so much cheaper to fly through
let's play this
so this is okay this position is
completely winning for a black it's just
a matter of
trying to win efficiently i think i want
to keep queens on the board
and just
try and get some mating attack
this is not the easiest structure to
break down
but i have some idea now of moving the
bishop and playing rookie 2
and targeting b2
[Music]
messages from so many people i might
have to end soon
hopefully not too soon uh when i started
the stream i was planning to only
stream for like an hour
um what's my uptime
someone can use uptime command i still
don't want to trade queens
how can i convince my eight-year-old
student to not play scandi
usually with especially with younger
kids i let them play any opening they
want
and just try and give them resources in
the openings that they uh
they're interested in playing
i don't want to trade queens he's being
annoying
let's put the queen on a6 i'm gonna put
the pawn on a4
and then move the queen back to b5
i've only been streaming for 20 28
minutes
okay so i guess i'll try and go for
another half hour
i've never been to finland i've heard
good things about finland though
i'm not too familiar with the chess
scene in finland though
okay let's remove the bishop
maybe he'll forget my queen is attacking
me too
please play rookie one hey he played
rookie one
so nice of him
i guess it was nice to have the queen
like far away
and have my bishop far away so generous
speaking of generous thank you galindra
for the sub
appreciate that
probably just pre-move the rest of the
moves
what does all of all this about like
farm fresh
openings i don't understand
but i think one d4 equals board games
board games spelled b-o-r-e-d
um i don't think d4
oh d4 has a tendency to be more
positional
because you don't castle as quickly
um with e4 games you castle quicker you
attack quicker
uh okay let's oh he mouse slipped
he mouse slipped ouch oh thank you
i wonder what move email slipped on
uh recap from this game um this
nice opening trap the stafford gambit
like white played two natural moves okay
d3 is a blunder
i should probably play like bishop e2 or
bishop c4
oh bishop c4 runs into bishop take f2 so
i should play bishop e2 here
probably not the easiest move to find
and then the rest of the game was
happiness for black
oh queen c1 was a mouse slip ah maybe
queen d1
yeah that would be well it's still still
crushing for black